emile est arrivé il ya trois ans ce
matin il participe à la mise en
bouteille de rosé sec 2019 chandelle
d'études alors j'ai vu plein
d'expérimentation plein de choses et
j'ai la chance de travailler ici
maintenant j'ai ma famille mon
exploitation et c'est assez grande avec
beaucoup vous placent donc on fait on me
fait confiance et j'ai la possibilité de
entreprendre plein de choses et on me
fait confiance et vol et lorsqu'il
trouve un moment depuis les vendanges
émile tik tok quand le vigneron choisi
ça chauffe
on parle de la chauffe intérieur de la
barre et qui ça veut dire que le
tonnelier lui va brûler l'intérieur
moyennement ou longtemps ça dépend parce
qu'on a choisi il parle à sa façon de
son métier de vigneron sur le réseau
social
d'abord choisir je me faisais ça va
sûrement intéresser les gens mais là oui
un jour j'ai posté une vidéo qui est
devenu complètement virale le café plus
d'un million de vues où j'explique
pourquoi ni une crash quand on déguste
et ben là je passais de 10000 à 120
mille abonnés en trois jours je me suis
pris une grosse claque en pleine figure
du coup la vidéo et je vais résister les
clips faut que ce soit un peu plus
dynamique
j'ai une petite vidéo sur un le type de
bois des barriques sauf que commence à
bien vient pour sujet au début les deux
jours que le d'emile qui gère le domaine
ont trouvé l'idée un peu bizarre quand
je vois que c'était mes enfants qui
regardent et tik tok j'ai dit je sais
pas dans quel monde et nous emmène
j'admets que voilà mes enfants elle se
fait déjà et puis après je vois que dans
la cour du lycée de ma fille et ben
pareil ils ont pris dix ans qui
connaissaient déjà et puis ma fille est
bien de dire une certaine fierté de diva
je te connais c'est mon cousin
chez les plus on cultive la vigne et
l'histoire familiale depuis 1508 513 ans
de louis xii et françois 1er jusqu'à tik
tok le grand écart historique
les quatre derniers patriarche
s'appelait ferdinand camille rollon et
benoît le père de guillaume et mathieu
on va l'excusé il est en petite tenue
le voici en tenue plus respectable avec
70 ans de plus allergiques toque du
temps de mon père c'était pareil ont
poussé mon père et à la hume pouces
c'est normal on peut partir en retraite
plus ou moins tranquillement vers le
savoir et nour dans la foulée le
prochain plue s'appellera peut-être
julien aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que les vidéos que
j'ai tourné belge détourné en compagnie
de france 3 centre c'est illégal et nous
nous retrouverons pour la première fois
sur un poste tik tok